juli 2010
die sich im hausflur
stehen
im zentrum von
raketen
wenn sie mich fragen des kosovo seien
auch ich habe das immer für mich da wenn
sie die wahl haben und keine fragen
sie mal fehler
sie vertrauen
sie hatten angst vor putin
dieser situation
schlimmste passieren
das
ist
[Musik]
jetzt
gewesen
250 kinder
vom bahnhof hier gebracht
warum
reaktion ganz klar
europa und die gesamte welt sie muss
verstehen dass
krimineller ist ein straftäter ein
killer vor dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof
gegen die auch
nach
stunden wird ich muss ihnen sagen
ist nicht
fünf oder zehn mal stärker
danke
dafür war sie bekommen
was wir eigentlich sehr wichtig ist
unerhört sei
aber eine flugverbotszone
was sie in deutschland
denn das ist ein schutz und nicht von
uns
vielleicht können sie das auch noch
diskutieren
aber fitter machen sie schnell es gibt
keine andere möglichkeit putin zu
stoppen
können auch
russische flugzeuge angreifen sie
zerstören wenn sie uns angreifen sagte
wir haben luftwaffen piloten
keine frage haben sich von den bereits
abgeschossen worden in dieser situation
sind auch die aus der ddr gekommen sind
als andere spox startete diese brauchen
uns war heute und morgen
sie hat amazon.com
bundeskanzlerin jedes jahr decken monat
haben sie immer darum gebeten gebeutelt
geradezu um waffenlieferungen zu
bekommen wie sehen sie die rolle von
frau merkel und auch die rolle
deutschlands
schlussendlich haben wir ja
bekommen
aber die rolle der bundeskanzlerin war
sicherlich eine andere von anfang an der
anfang meiner präsidentschaft von sechs
romanen amtseinführung deutschland
bundeskanzlerin mehr leben eine führende
rolle nicht nur in deutschland nicht nur
in europa sorge für die welt
so ist die umgegangen behandlungspause
konnte ihn zwingen
zu setzen was wir bräuchten heute angela
merkel
was aber jetzt die europäischen
politiker dem unternehmen können häuser
jetzt nicht morgen sondern teuer ist sie
müssen der welt zeigen dass
sie wirklich
sie müssen gemeinsam
sich zusammensetzen
das ist sicherlich
unbedingt eine wirksame
verhandlungsstrategie eins zu eins mit
puppen zu sprechen ich glaube dass nicht
ein theater mit putin bringt nichts denn
putin was macht er er fordert eine
entmilitarisierung
aber in wahrheit brauchen wir eine
entpolitisierung kein land der welt kann
heutzutage mehr mit einem putin stil
umgehen ansonsten sehen wir hier eine
nukleare katastrophe
bringt mir doch eben mal kurz über
wladimir putin sie haben ihn mehrfach
getroffen und sie sagen jetzt dass
so wie es aussieht
das existenzrecht der ukraine gesprochen
hat hat gesagt das ist kein land wie war
das damals mit ihnen als sie mit ihm am
verhandlungstisch gesessen haben
ja heute wäre meine antwort so wie es
präsident seitigen gesagt hat wer ist
dieser verdammte killer nicht welches
recht hat er grenzen
eines landes nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
zu verschiedenen ich glaube wir müssen
versuchen eine verhandlungs form zu
finden
unsere dass die sitzung die wir damals
hatten unmittelbar vor
dem nato-gipfel in cardiff im jahr 2014
75 hatten wir eine katastrophale lage
front wir hatten keine ahnung mehr wie
man die nicht geschaffte der musik kennt
die wissen das besser als ich wir hatten
damals gar nicht genügend geld gar nicht
genügend vermittelt um putin zu schlagen
später dann als ich über kommentieren da
war ich 14 20 15 konnten wir zwei
drittel des donners wieder befreien von
russischen truppen aber
wir haben gezeigt dass wir gut in 2010
stoppen können
februar 2015 noch einmal stoppen können
militärisch gut orchestriert und
angepasste methode szenario ihn zu
stoppen und glauben sie mir 2014 man die
fähigkeiten der ukraine deutlich
niedriger die unterstützung seitens des
westens kam gar nicht so nah an bei uns
aber jetzt
müssen alle verstehen alle politiker
müssen verstehen ich warte gestern haben
wir ja die landkarte
haben sie da gesehen auf der karte an
der wand dass er sagt dass
sein angriff auch nach süden führen
sollte bei der letzten frage sie sind
millionär sie könnten japan aus der
ukraine können wegfliegen gesehen aber
hier ein gepanzertes fahrzeug hinter
ihren soldaten
wie gefährlich ist das jetzt für sie
hier wie wahrscheinlich ist dass eine
rakete auch hier einschlägt
egal zu welcher zeit
können maske blieb kaliber oder
ballistische funke die iskander raketen
einschlagen egal wo überall montiert ist
das möglich sie wissen das besser als
ich und ich möchte ihnen auch danken
ganz herzlich sie waren 20 14 20 15 an
unserer seite
welche rolle haben sie
ausgeübt die wahrheit berichtetet das
haben sie getan auch ein wirksames
mittel gegen die fake news kampagne
bewusst
ich war nicht nur der fünfte präsident
der
ukraine nach europa kommunizieren
sondern ich bin keiner der ukraine
kämpfen für unseren land und
schlussendlich werden wir definitiv
gewinnen mit ihrer unterstützung
ganz herzlichen dank betrieb ihre
schenkel